NBC's massive hit this is us returned
last week this is you watching this is
us you see in this show I mean I've had
some time off I've been watching that
show I've been watching all of them yeah
the success of that show has taught us
one thing about TV viewers they loved
searing family drama
they just do well I thought why not add
a little of that to this show ladies and
gentlemen we're gonna do that right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Konan
what are you could have be done your
dinners getting cold honey and I've told
you a million times I'm working twice as
hard these days on the new show twice as
hard the shows half as long don't you
want to be with me honey
of course I want to be with you it's
just this new show it's it's taking
every last fiber of my being there's so
much change where's the band the band
lives on a farm in upstate New York
they're very very happy and what's with
this casual new getup I don't know what
it is this is what the focus group like
the best Sharon what it looks like a
strip club and Grand Theft Auto Andy
we're still working out the lighting
would you just get off my back honey um
I'm sorry I know this is hard that's
that's why I got you something you know
I love you honey oh my god time necklace
this looks expensive
there's something else you feel guilty
about what did you do
there is something else I have a secret
son
Milo get in here
my dad I knew mom Coenen this is not
your son he is way too ruggedly handsome
mom you you may be right but dad always
taught me that you've got to be kind of
the less attractive please
interesting the strangers just scamming
us for free food that's not important
all that matters is that we're a family
now
secret Sons leather jackets with ties
bands on farms gratuitous cameos what
happened to us
don't you see Andy this is us
[Applause]
Louis's Conan knew this spring on TV
nice big thanks some elements and even
right back
you